en banlieue parisienne dans les rues de
drancy bemba erre comme une âme en peine
en france il se sent un peu seul mais au
moins ici il est plus libre qu'au pays
demba et homosexuel est chez lui en
mauritanie sa sexualité est un crime
pour ça il risque même la peine de mort
réfugie en france il y a deux ans d'un
bar est très discret sur son
homosexualité
s'ils témoignent à visage couvert c'est
par peur d'être reconnue mais face à
notre caméra en confiance n'aime pas ce
livre c'est son propre cousin qu'il a
dénoncées aux autorités mauritaniennes
après l'avoir surpris avec son petit ami
le jour où on m'a arrêté j'étais avec
mon petit compagnon ils ont venir un cd
vous ne savez pas noir éthique nous
avons conduire vers une jambe et la
noquette rentrant dans le présent et ont
pesé qui m'a donné un coup de matraque
sur la tête et aussi m'ont donné la
légion oui en ce 4 août
deux semaines auparavant ce même cousin
avec une bande de jeunes mauritaniens
avaient lynché demba
et pour finir sa famille aussi la
rejeter avoir un fils homosexuel en
mauritanie est une honte voire une
erreur de la nature d'un bal lui-même en
garde les séquelles mais même s il me
l'a dit je voulais pas ça sinon moi moi
moi c'est tout un nom
mais c'est comme c'est une maladie lyon
que j'ai pas le faut parce que souza
quelquefois sais pas
[Musique]
si j'ai le
sida est en vie aujourd'hui et s'il a
rejoint la france c'est grâce à son
oncle qui a payé un gardien de prison et
un passeur ici il a demandé l'asile
politique mais pour le moment le statut
lui a été refusé et il n'a pas le droit
de travailler il habite un foyer
au nez et vous êtes combien dans la
chaude trop d'argent lors d'un cours
en mauritanie la famille de demba n'a
pas de problème d'argent là bas il
vivait dans son propre appartement
faisait des études ici ce n'est pas la
même histoire la situation est précaire
il doit se plier aux règles et ce matin
lui et la centaine de résidants du foyer
doivent changer les draps
quand même les gens sont chanson soleil
la situation
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est un jour important pour
demba il a rendez vous avec son avocate
une aide juridictionnelle dans les
demandeurs d'asile bénéficient depuis
l'année dernière
sa première demande auprès de l'ofpra
l'office français de protection des
réfugiés et apatrides a été rejetée il
fait appel de la décision auprès de la
cour internationale du droit d'asile
alors j'en profite pour vous dire quand
on va être reçue devant la cour du droit
d'asile il faut enlever son bonnet les
juges à chaque fois il n'aime pas quand
en garde un un chapeau un benêt à
l'audience comme ça vous prenez déjà
l'habitude donc franchement moi je j'ai
extrêmement étonné qu'avec un certificat
comme celui-là et deux récits successifs
l'ofpra guise tout simplement que
non je ne vous crois pas en fait disent
que vous n'avez pas bien expliqué que
vous êtes homosexuel on n'arrive pas
trop à y croire et pour prouver son
homosexualité d'un pas dû répondre à un
questionnaire d'une heure un peu
particulier est-ce que vous avez des
amis fille comment avez vous pu cacher
votre homosexualité à vos parents
comment s'en est rendu compte
il dit par exemple quand on est
homosexuel
tu dois tout faire pour ça se sache pas
je faisais un effort m for énorme sur
moi sinon le calvaire commence
eh bien ça ne suffit pas l'année
dernière demba a rencontré à paris un
jeune camerounais d'après son avocate il
serait préférable de présenter ce petit
ami à la cour le jour de l'audience
demba n'aura que 15 minutes pour
convaincre heureuse son show continue en
quatre langues on sait que ça peut nous
sommes comme rené ses compagnons - la
baie d'alger m si à ce moment là votre
ami est là et que moi je me tourne vers
la mi jeudi voyait son ami et là dans la
salle les couilles il est là au premier
rang ce serait quelque chose de tout à
fait positive bien sûr
nous avons rencontré un responsable de
l'ofpra pour comprendre quels sont les
critères de sélection pour obtenir un
statut de réfugié quand on est
homosexuel comme demba en fait c'est pas
franchement la sexualité de réfugiés qui
intéresse le fera ce qui intéresse
l'ofpra c'est les persécutions invoqué
les persécutions subies le récit de
l'intéressé et les craintes auxquelles
il peut être exposée en cas de retour
l'ofpra se défend d'être trop indiscrets
mais pour ces homosexuels pour chasser
évoqué ce qu'ils ont vécu face à des
policiers français n'est pas vraiment
évident alors pour libérer la parole il
y à l'art 10 c'est dans cette
association qui accueille les homos
persécutés différentes nationalités que
nous retrouvons demba il vient discuter
avec thomas un des bénévoles
la personne et est souvent assez
fermé dans sa parole est là elle a
appris à
refouler complètement l'expression de sa
sexualité de manière générale et est
encore plus de son homosexualité à
l'artiste qui a pu rencontrer d'autres
mauritanien tu as plus discutés avec eux
n'ont
pourtant y en a d'autres il faudrait que
tu les rencontres
tu pourra discuter de sa demande d'asile
avec eux ils ont la même situation que
toi il soit aussi homosexuel mais si tu
es moi je tente présenterez sont gentils
et tu pourras discuter avec eux
tranquillement oui c'est sa moue
c'est mieux de discuter avec le 1.6 sont
sympas en france 4 % des demandes
d'asile sont faites par l'ec est
persécuté neuf pays dans le monde dont
la mauritanie condamne l'homosexualité à
la peine de mort et plus de 80 autres la
punissent ce soir d'un bannira pas
dormir au foyer il ira retrouver son
petit ami camerounais mais s'il
n'obtient pas son statut de réfugié il
sera contraint de retourner en
mauritanie là bas c'est la prison voire
pire qui l'attend